we got our uh we got our resident
younglin here
good good
so
if the future is moving
closer towards you know universal basic
income everything's going to be taken
care of care for you so
my idea is you just play their game but
you play it better and the only way you
could do this
is through um
some sort of cryptocurrency based off
ethereum unlimited coins but
you know why do you go to college you
know why do you work you know a lot of
it is monetary basis okay so let's so
let's just go back to the notion of
ethereum being part of the solution yeah
yeah okay sure okay so
ethereum is decentralized mostly anyway
um
unlimited tokens yeah so why would the
government give up
their monetary system to adopt
a blockchain based system like ethereum
like ether
well you could say it's they're they're
kind of like trying to get rid of crypto
as is they're not big fans of it because
it threatens them obviously but the idea
is if the currency besides obviously
there's gonna be a fight for that but if
a currency could incentivize actions and
that this is how the future is going to
move and it's going to move in such a
way where you're going to be
incentivized to let's say oh you're
going to get paid if you walk your dog
or if you recycle or if you
drive an electric car
or if you say hello
that's all that's all fine and dandy but
i mean
the problem still remains the entire
purpose of government i don't think that
a lot of guys are getting this as
they're watching this right now even as
they're coming in the entire purpose of
government is centralized control
why would the government give up
centralized control and power that
they've exerted for decades like they've
gone from
you know we've gone from an environment
where men were at the head of the
household they controlled their lives
their house was their castle and all
within with their vassal like you know
all that sort of stuff
they've
you know we've gone to a place now where
the state is the head of the household
the government gets to decide even with
your 12 year old kid in your in your
household what medical
injections that they will take
yeah i'm with you there and so why would
the government give up control of a
monetary system
that they have full control over for
something that they don't well we're not
asking them to give up control it's
something that
like for example the government didn't
give cryptocurrency the voice to have
power or influence but yet it does so
what you're talking about is convincing
the public to adopt something
again the problem still you know still
comes back over to exhibit a where the
public doesn't support that notion the
public tells us
that by by their voting patterns that
they are supporting liberalism they are
supporting massive government with
massive control
so you're not going to have them you
know step away from that so long as
you know the vast majority of the
population believes that that's good
people don't want freedom again you know
they want free stuff and exactly exactly
and that's what this is
and it's free stuff based on actions and
whoever is free from the government
free stuff from big daddy government
free health care free dental
free accommodation free food
free everything is is better than
ethereum-based blockchain stuff
yeah that's that's their uh how do you
say their actions in order to benefit
you
so your solution is flawed because
because it assumes that the vast
majority of the public is smart enough
to see that as a better opportunity
right well not
it's dependent on the thing that they
are receiving for the action is it
valuable enough
isn't that that's where the they don't
the vast majority of the public sees
greater value in supporting big
government
they still do i mean where do you live
again you live in the states right yeah
yeah so i mean like
watch the election here on september
20th i think it is um you're gonna see
who you know comes out of this and it's
either going to be a minority liberal
government or probably a minority
conservative which is really liberal
light now here
um that's what the vast majority of the
population is going to vote for which is
going to mean big taxes less personal
freedoms vaccine passports will still
exist all that sort of stuff it's like
you know control control control control
government doesn't want to give up on
control government wants government
wants you under their thumb they want
you under that thumb so that you're
you're controllable they want you weak
no they want you stupid and they want
you plugged into lies now using your
example here uh so let's say you know
you're talking about children and child
care right and often the mom will like
go to work so what if
she was in that situation she realized
oh she could earn the same
amount for that day but if she parented
her own child and with incentivized
cryptocurrency actions and if you want
to have where does that money come from
see and and that's the thing it's it's
uh
you would you ha so a really great
example of this is a website called
steemit and they're trying to like
implement this uh action based where you
earn money based on actions
and
if you
so if you drop off your child and say oh
there's an alternative where i can make
maybe half that amount
equivalency okay but that doesn't exist
like there's no program in in place
aside from mother's allowance and child
tax credits and stuff like that like if
you're a
like if you went to university and you
got a stem degree as a woman and you're
making a hundred hundred fifty thousand
dollars a year and some stem field and
you've got your kid you know at 39 you
know you pop out your first credit 39
because you delayed it all to chase a
career sort of thing the government's
not going to pay you more than 150 000
that you're making work in your stem
career to stay home and raise that child
they would rather say
go work your stem career you know pay
your taxes
put your put your child in our child
care system yeah we'll take care of your
kid just trust us because we're the
government and we're good and we know
what's right and then we're going to put
them through our public school systems
and then we're going to indoctrinate
them with all this stuff that's going to
convince them to vote for more big
government
government keeps keeps the population
in this never-ending cycle of building
itself up bigger and bigger and bigger
and fatter and slower and the thing
against that is that what does
technology do technology squeezes out
the middle man it turns the horse and
buggy right but i mean you're still
you're still relying on the fact that
human beings are smart enough to see the
opportunity in that technology at the
upside people people don't vote for
freedom they don't want that technology
they want free [ __ ] it it's it's it's
always going to come back to this
exhibit over here it's what are they
doing like what is the population doing
and that's what they're doing
you see what i'm saying well it only
comes up i mean it's like
listen it's you know it's a great idea
it's a grand plan and i really hope that
at some point
a large part of the population wakes up
and says f this i'm going to
take advantage of this decentralized
platform that that day may come it could
be 10 years could be 50 years you know
what the entire monetary system could
collapse and they're forced to go to it
maybe the government's forced to move as
well it's not dependent on it collapsing
the idea here is like just like the
horse and buggy to the car the value has
to be
so equivalent to that where it's just
like as you say frying head to the
to the floor
where it's just like oh i would much
rather live this type of way if the
technology was there to support it like
uh vehicles at an affordable price now
it just has to be that no it's asking a
lot but it seems like
it could be
the
there that's fine okay i'm gonna stop
you there i'm gonna wrap up on a few of
these super chats and in the show thanks
brother
you